[MUSIC PLAYING]
YOSSI MATIAS: [INAUDIBLE]
artificial intelligence
and how it impacts anything
from social good to ambient
intelligence.
Let me start, actually,
with a personal reflection--
a recent experience I had
in the mountains of Rwanda.
I had the privilege to spend an
hour with a family of gorillas
in their natural habitat.
And it was fascinating to
see how they were interacting
with each other.
It's clearly-- they
have their own language.
And by the way, they didn't pay
much attention to my presence
there, as you can see.
But this reminded me of a
famous gorilla called Koko.
Koko actually learn to speak--
learned a language.
And she learned over 1,000 words
of vocabulary and 1,000 signs--
2,000 words in spoken English.
And it took her 46
years to learn it.
And she became quite
a celebrity, in fact--
made the cover of
"National Geographic."
But this also brings up
this interesting question--
in a way, many
people would not even
believe that a gorilla could
learn how to speak before Koko.
And the question is--
what else can we
teach about speaking?
How about computers?
Can we teach computers to speak?
Can we have a conversation
with computers?
How far can we take artificial
intelligence in that direction?
And if we do that, what
are the ramifications?
And while gorillas already
have their special language.
In computers, we actually
need to teach it from scratch.
So artificial
intelligence is actually
bringing some hope
in that direction.
But before actually
going deeper into that,
I'd like to talk
about another aspect
of artificial intelligence.
So first-- obviously, we're
seeing that in many products
around our life--
this is now one nice example
that I like, which is--
we all have our phones
taking pictures quite a bit.
If I'd like to search
for a photo out
of my ever-growing gallery.
Today, sometime, all I need
to do is to just search--
just search for Birds in Sunset.
And it could bring
those pictures to me--
these are actually from
my own photo galleries--
without ever labeling those.
And in a way, I don't
pay much attention
to it, which is one of
the magic of technology--
when we stop paying
attention-- when it just works.
So really we take
it for granted,
but it used to be magic--
the fact that we can actually
identify birds and sunsets
without ever labeling it,
without training it.
And this has really
become possible
by, obviously, advancements
in machine learning and AI--
more notably in deep learning,
deep neural networks.
And very simplistically,
an image taken as an input
to a deep learning network--
the pixels activate
those so-called neurons,
which are essentially a
computer program inspired
by how we believe some of
the branch functions work.
And then those neuron
activities is propagating
through the layers
until, at the end,
we have a classification--
whether it's a dog or a cat.
And the way in which
this network is built
is by training it
on many examples--
in a way, similar to how
we're training ourselves
to recognize a new object.
So obviously, this made huge
strides over the last decade.
And this technology is now--
I'm sure you heard it
many times recently.
But the beauty about
this technology
is that, while it can
be used for many fun
stuff, such as searching
images in our photo album,
it can also solve some
pretty serious problems.
And again, such
inspiring example
is what it can do in health.
And again, many of you heard
about diabetic retinopathy.
This is a condition that may
affect people with diabetics.
Actually, if not
treated, it can lead
to loss of vision, loss of
sight-- to blindness sometimes.
And the good news
is that doctors
can diagnose it by inspecting
an image of the retina.
The bad news is that
there's a huge shortage
of eye doctors, which put
at risk millions of people
worldwide to lose their sight.
And the inspiring example
here is that research
done a few years ago, where one
could train machine learning
models to help diagnosis,
which is empowered
with what experts can do, and
therefore compliment that.
And by doing that,
now all you need to do
is to bring a person
to a scanning device
to take a picture, have the
system help out with diagnosis,
and then save the
eyesight of that person.
This is actually an image
taken from [INAUDIBLE],,
a clinic in India, where there's
already a pilot going on.
So what has started
as a research,
became a realization--
is now actually already
deployed in places
such as India and Thailand,
which is very inspiring to us.
What other problems
can we solve?
And indeed, some of you
may have heard last year
about follow-up research
of looking into the retina.
And what started out
as an exploration--
what can we learn from an
image of the retina, perhaps?
Can we identify some other
characteristics of a person
just by looking at the image?
Turns out to actually have
discovery of phenomena
that we don't even know about.
The research published
showed that you
can identify some of
cardiac signals and risks
based just on the
image of retina--
a fact that was not known to
the medical community before,
which is a great example of
how technology can help us not
only solve known problems
or provide solutions
to known methods that we
want to solve but, also,
give us new insights that
we were not even aware of.
So this, obviously,
brings up more hope.
And indeed, just recently we
just announced these research
showing how we can train
machine learning models
with the right methodology
to help out with the scanning
to have an earlier detection
for lung cancer, which
is one of the deadliest
diseases out there.
And again, think
about all the impact
that we will have
with this technology.
So these are all very exciting
progress that we see worldwide.
And I'm really excited about
the possibilities for health.
But when we think about the
impact of AI to our world,
it's not only to health--
which is hugely important.
There are many other societal
problems that we can actually
address with AI.
And one such area that I'd like
to actually spend a few minutes
about is crisis response.
And crises are situations
where people find themselves
in danger.
And once somebody
is in crisis, they
have a very strong need
for help, for information,
for technology.
So to reflect on
that, I'm going back
to my own personal experience
8 and 1/2 years ago.
This was in December, 2010.
I have a team in Israel,
in Tel Aviv and Haifa.
And that day, I was
in our Haifa office.
And we had one of the deadliest
fires in the Carmel Mountains,
which is not too
far from the office.
So this picture was
taken by my camera.
I actually checked the
metadata on the picture.
It's by Google Nexus 1 phone.
And at that point, it
was clear-- there's
something going on.
But searching for
information on the internet
revealed very
little information.
And I was really eager to
ask questions, such as,
what should I be doing?
So I evacuate the office?
Should I alert people to leave
their homes or something?
And there was no information
available on the internet.
It wasn't until I called
the mayor's office--
I got a number with some
actionable information.
And actually, asking
my search team
to put this information
online, as a result,
for anybody searching
for the same stuff
that I was searching--
this was actually one
of our early launches
of actionable information
crisis response.
And later on, we
used it for dozens
of other such situations.
And we had a lot of investment
in crisis over the years.
But a couple years ago--
and I should mention that I
was not alone in doing this.
So what we see is that,
whenever there's a crisis,
people are turning to Google
to search for information.
You can see that, during
floods, during hurricanes,
during explosions, they're
looking for information
not only because they'd like
to learn about what's going on
but because they'd
like to take action.
They'd like to know what they
should be doing about it.
So to that end, we
actually built a team.
And we launched,
a couple of years
ago, a product within Search,
called SOS Alerts where,
every time there's
a big crisis, we're
trying to pull together
and provide the best
information that we can, so as
to help people about questions
such as, what's going on?
Where is it?
What should I be doing?
How can I help?
And since then,
unfortunately, there
are now a lot of
crises out there.
There were over 250 activations
worldwide and tens of thousands
alerts, which are
public alerts coming
from various
governmental agencies
directly into people's
phones, with a total
of over 2 billion
views on those crises.
Which-- in many
cases, we're hearing
about how helpful it is.
However, we also
learned, in the process,
there's certain crises that we
cannot provide a lot of health.
And in fact, one of the most
devastating natural disasters
is our floods.
Floods are affecting up to
230 million people per year
globally.
They are actually believed to
be responsible for over 6,000
fatalities per year globally.
And some of those can
be, perhaps, avoided,
if people would have
enough information.
Which typically-- we
just don't have it.
And we see those
examples, in fact--
when you do have
information about floods,
then people can take action.
So for example, this is
testimonial in places
that we did have
information about floods
and people could take action.
And just last week,
we saw an example--
actually, a very
beautiful example--
about how the Indian
government in Bangladesh
took action during
the Cyclone Penny.
And because there was a
pretty good prediction
about where the cyclone
is going to be heading,
they could take action.
And based on preparation
for many years
and a great execution,
they actually
managed to mobilize many
people and get them out
of the danger zone.
But there are many other
floods where, actually, this
is not happening.
The reason being--
for example, whenever
it is the monsoon season,
rivers are starting to rise.
And quite often, we
know that there's
going to be floods somewhere.
But we're not sure
exactly where.
And the difference
between knowing
just generally versus
knowing exactly
makes all the
difference in the world.
So what we can see
here is the situation
where the accuracy is not good.
You know that a flood
is maybe going there.
But if you don't know exactly
where it's going to happen,
people are not going to
take action, as we learned.
And governments
cannot take action,
because there's too
much area to cover.
So it's just not practical.
So the question is, can we
get these higher-accuracy
predictions?
And as I'm going to discuss--
indeed, this turns
out to be possible.
However, two years
ago, if you'd asked me
if it's possible to provide
this kind of flood forecasting,
I would say, I don't know.
Because there's a lot going
in into this computation
of predictions of flood.
So after some
exploration, we managed
to figure out that, actually,
we could do something about it.
And we did have some progress
on flood forecasting.
So the way we're
treating it is by, first,
taking very accurate
data elevation
models of the
terrain of the places
that we're trying to predict.
And this alone is a very
interesting and important
computational problem, based
on taking aerial imagery,
using machine learning to
reconstruct the terrain,
and then using machine
learning to recalibrate
what's going on there,
based on historical data.
Once we do that, we can
run thousands-- sometimes,
hundreds of thousands--
of simulations,
using physical models,
hydraulic models,
where we try to anticipate
where the water is going to go.
In order to do that,
we need to have
some readings of the
water, so that we
can base our computations on.
And we have here a partnership
with the Indian government
to gather exactly this data.
And of course, all that
needs to be done per place,
because the soil
may be different.
We need to match it
versus past experience.
So there's a lot going
on in order to do that.
And getting into this
effort, it wasn't clear
whether this is feasible or not.
It turns out that it is.
And indeed, just last year, we
announced the pilot in Patna,
this bluish area
that you see here,
where we had accuracy of
90% prediction a few hours
before the floods themselves,
which was very encouraging.
So we doubled up on that.
And we already had an
activation back in September,
where we could actually
send out to people's phone,
with 90% accuracy,
the area where
the flood is going to occur.
So based on that, we doubled up.
And now, we are expanding.
And we expect our effort to go
and cover order of magnitude
into much of the rivers
in India and help out
many more millions of
people and then, also,
work on disseminating
the information,
so people could just
get notifications
on their phone,
which will drive them
into the alert about
what's going on.
And they could even go to
Map to go deeper and navigate
themselves.
So this is very
encouraging-- to see
how exploration of
something that we don't even
know possible turned out to
be something that is feasible.
And we're very excited
about the collaboration
also with the government.
But I'd like to also point
out another instance of how
AI can be used by everybody.
And this is another
very inspiring example.
These are two high school
students, Sanjana and Aditya,
who actually took
machine learning models
from TensorFlow.
And they built up
small devices, using
some parts they put themselves.
And they put them in various
areas of their forest
in California to learn.
And they trained the
models to identify
when there is a risk of
fire because of deadwood
and other parameters.
And by being able to
alert about the risk,
they could actually send
notifications to Cal Fire,
so they can prioritize
going to check these areas
and, hopefully,
prevent some fires.
And the fact that you can
have two high schoolers take,
off the shelf, libraries
and just use them and solve
an important problem, I
think, is a great opportunity
that we have today.
And it's just increasing.
So if we think about
these two examples,
these are good illustrations
of why we started the Google AI
for Social Good program, where
we're looking more closely
into a how to first double
up or focus on our research
in engineering around
these societal problems
and, on the other hand, how we
work with building an ecosystem
and supporting the ecosystem,
with the realization that we
cannot solve all
problems obviously.
And in many cases,
actually, we're
not even aware of the
problems that could be solved.
So the opportunity for
everybody to actually pitch
in and identify
problems and bring
their own expertise, I
think, is a great opportunity
that we have.
And along with the program, we
announced the Impact Challenge,
where we asked everybody
to come and submit a grant
and apply for
grants and support.
And we just announced
the 20 winners
for that, which are coming
from all over the world
and are also
touching many areas--
agriculture and
emergency services.
And some of them are
about societal issues.
about suicide prevention.
So we see a lot of variety.
But also-- it was
great to see-- we
had over 2,600 applications
from 119 countries.
And 40% of them--
without any background
in machine learning.
So the hope is that, for
many of them, perhaps,
getting some
mentorship and exposure
is going to actually
help them even accelerate
some of the
developments in areas
where machine learning
can actually help.
And indeed, in addition
to the monetary funds,
we're going to kick off
support by a program
that we have called
Launchpad, which is
about mentorship of startups.
So the notion of working with
the community is not new.
In fact, we have
Launchpad program
that has been running
now for a few years.
And we are focusing now on
Launchpad Accelerator that
provides mentorship on
machine learning and AI
to startups all over the world.
We had over 200 startups
going through that program
and thousands of startups going
through mentorship in general
by Launchpad.
And Launchpad is
a global program.
In fact, it started in
our office in Israel,
experimentally.
And since then, it's been
running in Israel, in Africa,
in many other countries.
And by the way,
talking about Africa--
it's great to see
talent going everywhere
and how to encourage that.
So I was inspired,
visiting there last year,
when we inaugurated a program
called the African Master
for Machine Intelligence--
and getting to talk with
some of the students who
are representing the next
generation of leaders.
And again, this is a
kind of reinforcement.
And whenever I go
everywhere in the world,
you can see that, really, the
talent, the entrepreneurship,
the opportunity is everywhere,
which is really exciting.
Let me also point out that, when
we think about collaboration
in community, it's not only
big companies and startups
and NGOs.
Sometimes, there's
an opportunity
to do even broader
collaboration.
So I'll just highlight
this collaboration
that we're having
with the World Bank
and the United Nations
and additional tech
companies to try and address
the problem of famine.
So it turns out
that, even today,
famine is a big
problem worldwide.
It can impact
millions of people.
And one of the single
most important items
to help these people is to
identify famine early enough--
not wait X months after it
happened to then take action.
So we have collaboration
where we're
trying to help out on developing
with machine learning models
that can identify the
indicators of food security
and, thereby, enable the World
Bank and other organizations
to take actions earlier--
to divert resources before
it becomes a real crisis.
So the opportunity
to have collaboration
on a large scale
and global scale
by everybody for social good--
and incorporating
AI to do that--
I think, is pretty significant.
Now with that, I'd like to
actually switch gear and talk
about--
oh, one last note about it
is that, even on floods,
where we're focusing a lot
and we have a sizable team--
even here, we understand
that we can only
talk about a small
subset of the problem.
And there are many
problems that aren't floods
that we don't necessarily
have the expertise.
So just recently we brought
together some 80 researchers
and people working
for governments
and other organizations
to discuss
how we could bring together
expertise in hydrology,
in physics, and machine learning
and have this conversation
to see how we can actually,
together, tackle these problems
and get some more
progress on that.
And with that, I'd
like to switch.
So if AI here is about how
to solve societal problems
and really impact people's
lives-- sometimes,
saves those lives, save
the site, make them safe--
there is another
domain where I find
that AI is becoming increasingly
more significant in our lives.
And I'd like to talk a little
about conversational AI,
about how we can have
conversations among ourselves.
So going back to the questions
raised by [INAUDIBLE],, so many
of us grew up on the
aspirational magical experience
of Star Trek.
Could we ever speak with a
computer in a natural way,
like we do with a person, just
ask questions, get answers,
get advice?
We don't need to
learn new methodology.
We have the interface.
That's what we do.
And in fact, this goes
back even to Alan Turing,
founder of computer science.
He was already asking the
question about, can people
talk to computers,
much in the same way
that they talk to
each other, famously
known as the Turing Test.
Now, just think about it.
If you could have
this conversation,
obviously, it makes it
accessible to many more people.
Because all you need
is to ask the question
or to ask for
something to get done.
So this is, obviously,
a big problem.
But we've seen some
progress in recent years.
And many of them-- actually,
we don't pay much attention.
So today, many of
us already, when
they want to search
for information,
they would just
ask their phones.
Many would just talk to
their assistant or the phone
to set up an alarm.
And it should just work-- right?
There are hundreds or
thousands of different ways
in which you'd like
to set your alarm.
And you expect it to just work.
And of course, there are
many other situations
in which we'd like to use
conversational technology.
And the reason why we're making
this progress, of course,
is by having speech
recognition, which
is becoming better and better.
And the ability for
speech synthesis--
to take text and to
read it back to user.
And there are
additional ingredients
of a conversation that we
have had some progress on.
So for example--
Smart Reply.
Whereas-- we have a question.
We can get a guess about
what the answer may be,
just based on experience,
which is actually
sometimes surprising.
Some people are
offended by the fact
that they're a
little predictable.
Smart Compose is
another example.
In fact, this technology,
at some point, I believe,
some April Fools'
joke by some folks.
And today, they
are just working.
And it's pretty
magical when it does.
These are two ingredients.
But I'm very
excited about, also,
the technology that we can
actually speak a text--
the text-to-speech synthesis,
which became very natural.
So for example-- could
we just listen to pages?
So in fact, we
launched last year--
and we have a version of
the Google application
that works in India and
Brazil and other places
where, sometimes, you have
lower-end phones or internet
connection, which
is constrained.
It's called Google Go.
And we launched with the ability
to just read whenever you
see the browser or web page.
You should just listen to it.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- Up to 15% of slots,
from the new runway
would be dedicated to
improving domestic connections,
and the government hoped that
the increased competition
with existing routes would give
greater choice to passengers.
[END PLAYBACK]
So this is an example
that you can just
listen to the page in your
Google Go application.
And the beauty here-- this
also highlights the words.
So obviously, it's
for convenience.
But for many people,
it turns out,
it's quite important,
because of literacy--
if they find it difficult to
read the text, either because
of literacy issue
or because it's
a foreign language to them.
And we just announced
using the same technology
to solve related problems, such
as "what did you see text."
You're on the go.
You're on the street.
You'd like to understand
what's going on.
Today, all you need
with, again, Let's Go,
is to point out your camera to
that-- your telephone to that--
and to hear what's--
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Information for cardholders--
all customers using old,
proprietary, magnetic stripe
cards should be advised.
[END PLAYBACK]
And the beauty about
technology is that, now, we
can start to put them
together and connect them
in various shapes
and various forms.
So for example, Translate
is technology that
used to be science fiction.
But today, we just
expect it to work.
You open a web page.
It's in a different language.
You hit Translate.
And you see it.
And it's pretty good.
It still have room
for improvement.
But you get a sense of it.
So what if we just
bring them together?
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- [SPEAKING SPANISH]
[END PLAYBACK]
Just by putting them together,
suddenly, we reduced barrier.
Suddenly, a person that could
otherwise not read the sign,
for some reason, cannot
hear what's going on there.
Now, another
inspiring project was
developed by Dimitri and Chen.
So Dimitri is deaf.
And he worked on taking the
speech recognition technology
and making it work in what
we call Live Transcribe.
So you can just listen
to the conversation
and seeing it on your phone.
And this has been, now,
going on for some time.
But when you think
about these technologies
of speech recognition--
text-to-speech-- there's
more that we can do.
So if you cannot hear today,
we can just click on the button
and get those live captions,
which we just announced.
And think about people
who cannot hear.
Now, everything that
your phone is talking
becomes available for them.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Do you like the blueberries?
- Yeah.
- Blueberries?
Delicious.
A couple more.
Mm.
[INAUDIBLE]
[END PLAYBACK]
So you can apply it for,
essentially, anything
that your phone
would sound to you.
And if you think about
it, for some people,
it's actually making
the difference
between understanding what's
going on and what not.
For many, or for all of
us, it's really about
when you get into
situations that you just
don't want to hear the sound or
you just want to also read it.
Now, the way I'm
thinking about it
is that this is
really re-imagining
what the Mute button is.
Mute is not about, I don't
want to know what's being said.
It's about, I don't want
any noise to be made.
So you can actually
just cross modality.
You can just move the hearing
from the modality of audio
to a modality of screen.
And if you think about
removing barriers and the fact
that, with technology
today, we can just
move the conversation in a
fluent way between modalities
or have them in both
modalities, from audio to text,
from text to audio, the
opportunities are plenty.
And we have more
examples-- right?
So now, going back to Dimitri.
He can hear what other
people are saying,
because we have voice
recognition that works pretty
well for those who are
talking with common accents
and common pronunciation.
But when he's speaking--
because he has a heavy accent
and he became deaf
at a younger age--
our speech recognition
devices actually don't really
understanding him very well.
And you've seen it before.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[END PLAYBACK]
So the premise of--
just talk to your phone
and get stuff done--
doesn't quite work for him.
And this doesn't quite
fit our commitment
to make Google work for
everyone and to make
technology work for everyone.
So we embarked on this
project, Euphonia,
which actually was starting
out by asking ourselves,
can we help ALS patients,
whose speech deteriorates,
to be understood?
And we trained and we built up
technology that can actually
take personalized training of
models for speech recognition.
And Dimitri actually
took these models.
He worked with our engineers.
And he's put a lot
of time to train
on thousands of sentences.
And the result was actually
quite not what we expected.
The error rate that
he's getting is actually
in par with what we're
getting on a regular speech
recognition.
Of course, this is
still in research stage.
And we need to find
ways not to rely
on those thousands of training.
But here's the example
of what we get today.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[END PLAYBACK]
So this is pretty
transformative, of course.
And again, we are getting
some very positive feedback
from ALS patients
who we're working
with about the ability for them
to express themselves in a way
that, now, it can be understood.
So I'm really excited
about this technology.
And again, as it goes
with accessibility--
interestingly
enough, quite often,
when you develop
for the hard cases,
it turns out that you can make
progress for many more cases
that you think about.
So for example, the team
wrote a research paper,
which showed that the
same technology that
is used for those
extreme cases can
have a tremendous
improvement over known data
sets with accents.
And the way this works is,
essentially, applying--
building up models,
training data
sets, based on
visual spectrograms,
then training them.
And we need plenty of them,
in order to really build it
in a personalized way.
So these are the different kind
of fingerprints, if you will,
of the diverse
spectrograms that are here.
So these are all good.
And when we talk me into our
phone and with our assistants,
this is the problems that
we're typically facing.
But I actually want to
go a little bit back
to an older technology--
the phone.
And I appreciate
that some of you,
perhaps, are not familiar
with this device.
So this is a phone,
as it used to be
at some point in the past.
So it turns out that, even
though much of our activities
are with our assistants,
with our phones,
there are plenty of
cases that people still
need to pick up the phone
to make a conversation.
And for example, it turns
out that, even though you'd
expect that a lot
of what we do today
is just online
reservation, et cetera,
60% of businesses in the US
that are relying on reservation
do not have an online
reservation setup.
And if you really
want to talk to them
or to do something with them,
you need to pick up the phone.
And pick up the phone--
so we need to take care of that.
And then, pick up the phone,
sometimes, is irritating.
And for some, it's impossible,
either because of circumstances
or because accessibility
of other reasons.
So to that end, we
announced last year Duplex,
which enables one to have a
phone call made on their behalf
by the assistant to
make phone reservations
and to do it in a
pretty natural way.
And indeed, today,
this is already
working in 44 states in the US.
And we get some great feedback
from users and from businesses.
And what enabled
Duplex to do the job
is really combination
of many technologies.
And they have to
do with analysis
of the audio source and
the speech recognition
and the text-to-speech
and, of course,
using deep learning networks
that are built for that,
because we need
to understand also
the intent of the conversation.
And all that is possible,
because we focused
on very specific domains.
So we could actually
build those models
in the way that work
sufficiently high-quality.
To do that, along with a
lot of machinery around it,
it touches real-time
supervised trainings and more.
And of course, we
also added to that.
Since our aspiration was to have
a very natural conversation,
then we added those particular
speech disfluencies, which
are part of the communication.
They are part of
the conversation.
They are actually part
of how we communicate.
It's part of how
we're saying, no,
in a soft way, in a polite way.
It's how we acknowledge, while
waiting for the other side
to actually talk to us.
There's actually a
field in linguistics
called Pragmatics, which looks
into some of these speech
disfluencies.
And these, put in
all together, enables
us to have a conversation
that is natural
and can achieve this goal.
So there are many
other natural ways
in which natural
conversation could help us.
And I really encourage
everybody to think
and to apply their imagination
about what can be done.
In fact, some time
ago, I was having
a conversation with my wife
about conversational AI.
So she actually pointed
out to me an opportunity.
She actually
challenged me-- well,
if you can do conversational
AI, why can't you
solve this problem for me?
And then she pointed out that,
every time the phone calls
and there's an unknown
number, she has a dilemma.
Well-- perhaps it's a sick
child or a sick parent.
But if she would
answer the phone,
then it's likely going
to be somebody trying
to set her on a cruise
or a new insurance, which
is pretty annoying.
And I'm sure we've
all experienced that.
So could we use conversational
AI to help with that?
Could we use it to actually
take some of the burden from us,
give us back our control of
our time, of our attention,
et cetera?
So indeed-- fast
forward-- we announced
just a few months ago, a
feature called Call Screen.
And Call Screen is
utilizing conversational AI
in a basic way to really answer
the phone on your behalf,
if you'd like to,
on unknown numbers,
and to help you figure
out who's calling,
by asking the other side
and then showing you
the result in real-time,
by transcribing it to you
and then enabling
you to actually ask
some additional questions and
eventually pick up the phone
or decline or just report spam.
And really, this is
facilitated by a combination
of all these technologies--
of speech recognition,
of text-to-speech synthesis.
And everything runs on device.
So it can be offline.
It's totally private.
And the fact that it
can run on a device
is really one of the significant
advancements that we've seen.
And you've heard
about it as well--
the fact that we can actually
do things, which is instant,
isolated, it's yours,
and it doesn't actually
leave your device.
So obviously, this is a
highly popular feature,
because everybody can relate to.
It was actually interesting
to hear from people,
not only how happy
they are for never
need to speak with
telemarketing again,
but you also heard from a few
people that, because of that,
they actually took a call
that they would otherwise
ignore that turned out to
be a hugely important call.
So think about it as a way to
help get control of our time,
of our attention.
And of course, this can
go a long way as well.
So one direction in which
this can go is actually,
again, coming from an
engineer on my team
who came to me one
day and say, hey,
my heart is really
with accessibility.
And I'd like to take
Call Screen and extend it
so that people who are deaf
could have a full phone
conversation, by adding
additional technologies.
And here, in order to do that,
you need to be synchronous.
You need to be able
to type in real-time.
But then we could use
all those features
that we mentioned earlier--
Smart Compose, Smart Reply.
And indeed, this is
still in research stage.
But this is an example.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[PHONE CHIMING]
- Hi, this is Nicole's
assistive chat.
She'll see what you say.
And her responses will be read
back to you-- starting now.
- Hi, Nicole, it's Jamie.
How are you?
- Hey, Jamie.
I'm good.
And you?
- Great-- are we still on for
your 1:00 PM haircut tomorrow?
- Sorry-- can you do 3:00 PM?
- Uh-- yes.
I can do 3:00 PM.
We have a lot to catch up on.
I want to hear all
about your trip.
- Perfect-- thumbs up.
- Great, see you tomorrow.
Bye.
[END PLAYBACK]
So think about everything
that comes together
in order to facilitate this--
speech recognition,
text-to-speech,
guessing how to
type, helping it out.
But think about the
ramifications of that.
It means that,
essentially, a person
could have a regular phone
conversation on the one hand.
The other person doesn't need
to talk or hear, perhaps,
because they cannot
talk or hear.
Perhaps, it's not
convenient to them.
Perhaps, it's a new
generation that doesn't
like to talk on the phone.
They are just used to chatting.
This is cross-modality.
Perhaps, you're in a
meeting or on a flight
and you'd like to take a phone
call over some other ways.
And think about-- if we would
integrate, in the future--
say-- translation--
the opportunity
to actually have a
conversation with somebody
in different language, totally
seamless, totally ambient,
in a way that, actually,
we don't pay attention--
just reducing barriers.
It just lets people to
communicate in a better way.
So these are pretty exciting
opportunities, I think.
I think these are
examples where we're
solving a problem,
sometimes, for one person
or because we're
excited about it.
And then it turns out to
solve a bigger problem.
But in many of these examples--
to reflect from them--
many of them were
actually situations
that we not necessarily
anticipated.
They came out from a single
passion or from exploration.
Or in the case of
flood forecasting,
we didn't know
that it's solvable.
Actually, even when starting
Call Screen and Live Relay,
it wasn't clear
that we can actually
put the technologies altogether
to get to the right level.
Until we start, we don't
even know that we do that.
And I was reminded
of that, actually,
in a recent vacation
in Spain when
having a morning run
and, at some point,
deciding spontaneously
to take a detour
and found these amazing bays
and landscapes that otherwise I
would miss.
So I think that research and
technology have this nature
that, quite often, we need
to have this exploration
and we need to try.
And that's some of the magic
that's happening on those.
Now, reflecting on where we
are with conversational AI--
I think we're in
very exciting times.
Think about all the
technologies and everything
that could happen if we have
all these technologies get
to a much, even better accuracy,
in a way that we don't even
pay attention to them.
Think about the barriers
that can be reduced,
the fact that every
person can ask a question,
can get stuff done in a
seamless way, in an ambient way.
The magic is that, when
the technology just works,
it becomes totally ambient.
That's what I'd like to think
about as ambient intelligence.
And another reflection
is, if we think back,
today, we're having
all these technologies
and all these products
that a few years ago
were just aspirational.
We didn't even know if we
can actually solve them.
We didn't know that
actually today we
could have these conversations
and hear back and have all
this stuff just working for us.
Which interestingly, if
you think about the future,
what is it going to entail?
So it's very
difficult to predict.
But I think that one can expect
that, even though I don't think
we're going to see anytime
soon a "Beam me up, Scotty"
kind of technology, for many
other technologies, if you
can dream them, you can
probably build them.
Thank you very much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]